we are running against a president who
is a pathological liar a fraud a racist
a sexist a xenophobe
we need leadership that brings us
together not divides us president I
didn't need to do this but I'd rather do
it much faster and I don't have to do it
for the election I've already done a lot
of wall
president Trump got it right when he
said he didn't have to do this
[Music]
also coming up tonight the high collars
and high life of German fashion designer
Karl Lagerfeld the world's most
recognizable catwalk dandy has died you
know a fashion is not needed today their
mayoral problems in the world who may be
more important so this is not the
problem but it's an industry and you
know fashion has to go with time if it
doesn't go with times fashion would be
lost
[Music]
the to our viewers on PBS in the United
States and all around the world welcome
we begin the day taking the president to
court on Monday a coalition of 16 US
states led by California and New York
filed a lawsuit for president Trump's
use of emergency powers Trump declared
on Friday a national emergency in an
attempt to free up billions of dollars
to construct a wall along the border
with Mexico
by declaring an emergency Trump set in
motion a constitutional confrontation
the attorneys general of those 16 states
say that the president has abused his
power
arguing Congress not the president has
the authority to decide where and how
money is spent if the courts side with
the state's legal scholars say the
argument to impeach the president will
be as strong and as clear as ever they
were doing it in full view of the White
House a new jersey in Texas in South
Carolina and in Colorado to a grassroots
sure force in opposition to the u.s.
president
[Music]
and because Colorado would be hurt by
this illegal action having funds that
are dedicated to be spent here moved
elsewhere
we will be joining an action to
challenge this there are among sixteen
states to challenge what they see is a
cash grab
taking disaster relief money to pay for
a more than two thousand kilometer long
vanity project on the Mexico border
the wall standoff came to a head on
Friday when President Trump said he
would invoke a rarely used power
bypassing Congress to fund his campaign
promise I could do the wall over a
longer period of time I didn't need to
do this but I'd rather do it much faster
for his opponents that statement
appeared to undermine his case there's a
crisis President Trump got it right when
he said he didn't have to do this no
pressure is mounting from within his
republican party with senators objecting
I think it's a bad idea whether the law
is currently written permits it or not
if it does then I think it's a moment to
sort of study whether Congress has
delegated too much power to the
executive but I actually I just think
it's a bad idea as he arrived back at
the White House Donald Trump may have
missed the protests but the brewing
political row will be harder to escape
and my colleague Helen Humphrey is on
the story for us tonight in Washington
DC good evening to you Ilana the u.s.
president we heard it right there he's
admitted that he did not have to declare
an emergency but he did so anyway did he
throw these 16 attorneys general a big
bone in their lawsuit good evening to
you Oh Brent will you you know as you
mentioned there it was one of those
freewheeling trumpian speeches in which
he said that he didn't have to declare a
state of emergency he did it in order to
build the wall faster and therein lies
the crux of the problem essentially and
certainly the illegal immigration
numbers do not stand up to support
declaring a state of emergency we're
currently seeing them at some of the
lowest levels in 45 years
and you know the California Attorney
General himself Xavier Becerra said that
this move and his complaint could you
know violate the Constitution in terms
of a bypassing Congress and their
control over the federal purse strings
not to mention the balance of powers the
tenant of the American Constitution in
the separation of powers between
Congress the president and the courts
but whilst President Trump was out there
making that speech he also said that he
anticipates this to go through the legal
system all the way up to the Supreme
Court and previously the Supreme Court
sided with President Trump for example
when it comes to the travel ban also
consider the constellation of the
Supreme Court Brett Kavanaugh had
previously said the Justice there that
he's in favor of expansion of
presidential powers so the outcome is
not clear-cut in this yeah that's a very
good point to make if though the ports
do decide to block funding for the wall
and they rule against the emergency
declaration could the scene be set for
Democrats in Congress to begin
impeachment proceedings against
president Truong well if the Supreme
Court would block the wall and that came
before the presidential elections Trump
might not even secure a second term
because that is one of the key campaign
issues for him and but certainly this is
something that the Democrats have
already opened an investigation into and
bear in mind they have many other
investigations going on since they took
control of the house following the
midterm elections and they're looking
into for example his ties with Russia
his taxes a whole host of issues not to
mention the Malheur investigation which
is set to drop as well all of these
could be impeachable issues but of
course for impeachment to follow through
you need a two-thirds majority in the
Senate and not to mention the question
Brent that you and I have discussed in
the past how political norms changed
beyond all recognition that would
actually allow for an impeachment that's
also a very good point and when we talk
about this border wall controversy we're
talking about an issue that will be part
of the 2020 election today Bernie
Sanders we all remember him
the Vermont senator who challenged
Hillary Clinton for the 2016 Democratic
bid well he announced that he's running
again
have a listen our campaign is not only
about the feeding Donald Trump the most
dangerous president in modern American
history it is not only about winning the
Democratic nomination in the general
election our campaign is about
transforming our country and creating a
government based on the principles of
economic social racial and environmental
justice so he'll endure what's the
reaction been in the United States to
Sanders announcement Vanity Fair says
that there are already a lot of
left-leaning
many Me's meaning copies of Sanders
running for the office right it's
certainly fair to say that it's already
a crowded Democratic playing field out
there and previously in 2016 I mean
Sanders was the alternative to Hillary
Clinton now many more candidates out
there I mean perhaps he's a victim of
his own progressive success to a certain
extent in that many people are out there
a campaigning on his core values that
said he's no longer the underdog he
knows that previously he took 19 states
in the primaries in 2016 so he has that
political capital under his belt going
forward and well compared to last time
Trump was still an untried and tested
opponent now he's got something firm to
go up against in his campaign video he
said that this man is a pathological
liar a racist a xenophobe sexist as well
at the end of the day this is still the
Bernie Sanders that some people love or
hate I mean he made that announcement on
public radio to Vermont first and some
people say you know that is just pique
Bernie yeah that is pique birdie that's
a very good point after the losses in
2016 he said that the Democratic Party
had failed and needed to be rectified is
he satisfied them with what we saw with
the midterm elections and the results
from that I mean does he think that the
party has changed
well the midterms were enough to take
back Congress to take back the house I
should say but not the whole of Congress
I mean I think it's interesting to see
that we have seen a shift in the left of
the party Bernie Sanders was considered
radical now many other candidates are
campaigning for example on Medicare
reducing tuition fees a living wage
action on climate change all of these
things that were very much a put forward
by Bernie Sanders and it's now he is
saying that you know if you're going to
all campaign on these issues it should
be not my name on the ticket essentially
I mean he's putting it in far more
diplomatic language than that what we
might start to be seeing now in the
Democratic Party is efficient emerging
we saw senator Kamala Harris out
campaigning at a rally in New Hampshire
and she said make me no mistake I am NOT
a socialist and Bernie Sanders describes
himself as this Democratic Socialist and
so she may then appeal to more moderate
Democrats more centrist than perhaps
people who are undecided whether they
would give Trump a vote for a second
term come 2020 so he certainly needs to
make some inroads there yeah it's all
about the S word it seems are Helena
Humphrey on the story for us tonight in
Washington Helena thank you
you